[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
we all have goals right hashtag goals
but smartphones also have goals or at
least we have smartphone goals we see
all these crazy concept renders of the
iPhone eight and they look ridiculous
obviously but in the coming months
they're gonna be more and more popular
and like clockwork in August and
September this year it will be peak
iPhone rumour hypetrain season and these
videos will be the ones that are shared
the most but I think everyone kind of
knows or at least most people know that
that's not actually the next iPhone but
we are taking steps to get closer to
that reality
so for proof these are five super
distant future smartphone features and
their roots in today's products so
number one is the bezel is display
concept I mean look at this just look I
mean this is the dream for some people
right now you might think about it for
an extra second or two and realize wait
a second there's no place for my fingers
like there might be accidental screen
presses or where did the webcam go
where's the speaker's now but just
ignore all that for a second and just
look at it this at its core is an
awesome concept it looks cool you can't
help but stare at it
videos would look awesome on the screen
taking pictures would look crazy like it
just looks like the future now Samsung
knows that and they made this the galaxy
s7 edge last year not only does the
display and the glass wraparound right
up to the edge of the phone but they
dropped in some actually pretty useful
edge display features too so the whole
UI really melts over the edges looks
pretty futuristic plus obviously videos
and photos look cool too and Samsung
also made the Galaxy Note 7 this way but
we all know how that ended up but I'd
expect more of that whole edge display
stuff in the Galaxy Note 8 and the
Galaxy S 8 and then you all saw the
video of the Xiaomi me mix which pushes
the bezel less display concept a little
further right up to the point where it
pushed the webcam and the earpiece
speaker right off the top of the phone
now the web can actually return down at
the bottom which is a little awkward but
not the worst thing in the world since
you can turn the phone upside down but
the earpiece speaker didn't return
instead they built in what's called a
piezoelectric speaker which vibrates the
glass on the front of the phone itself
to produce sound that you hear when you
put it up to your ear and it actually
works pretty well all of that to achieve
a display that just goes right up to the
edge of the device worth it so bottom
line
edge to edge glass is a thing it might
not be exactly
like the concept but it still looks
really cool in real life overall I give
the feasibility of this concept and
eight out of ten so number two is the
future of wireless charging so we always
want our phones to be charged up right
and wires are fine and they work in
everything but a bunch of phones now
have wireless charging where you can
place your compatible phone on a
compatible little pad without any wires
and your phone is charging I mean
technically there's still a wire
connecting it to the wall but
technically there's no wires connected
to your phone so we'll call it wireless
charging but you still have to have your
phone in like one exact little spot to
charge and you can't even really pick it
up and use it without it stopping the
charge so it's almost less convenient
than wired charging the dream is just to
be able to walk into a room with your
phone and it's wirelessly charging just
like that you don't even have to worry
about it but that's a long way off but
we do have in development today is
somewhere in between long-range wireless
charging is what it's called and I don't
think we'll ever safely get to that
whole full-on walk into a room and start
charging gold but various companies are
working on long-range wireless charging
with stuff like lasers with ultrasound
even and with radiofrequency so there's
a bunch of ways to do this whole
wireless charging thing from a couple
inches to a couple feet away the biggest
challenge with this one is definitely
compatibility though even now we have a
bunch of different wireless charging
standards among smartphones but I think
a pretty good bet is whichever Apple
chooses for their next wireless charging
iPhone the first one that they do will
have a pretty big impact on the future
like I said one of the reasons Apple got
rid of the headphone jack on the iPhone
7 is that's another step marching
towards their eventual goal of a
completely port 'less completely
wireless iPhone somewhere down the line
in order to get to that they eventually
have to remove that last port which is a
charging port and in order to do that
you need wireless charging overall I'm
giving us concept a 7 out of 10 so
number three is voice control of all the
things and I really like this one I
actually think voice control is pretty
good as it already is and it's useful
for a lot of people but I think the goal
the real goal is to have this sort of
closest as possible to a all knowing
human like personal assistant I've ever
listened to logics the incredible true
story where they're just on the
spaceship and he's asking the computer a
bunch of random facts and things to do
and it knows how to do everything even
how to make jokes
you just upgrade features they enhanced
her AI so she can actually hold a
conversation yeah ask her yourself what
am I thinking Thalia hi I'm a program in
the ship's interface not a psychic D
girl yeah that's another thing now that
I think that right there is the ideal
voice assistant in its most helpful form
so with enough computing power and a
complete enough knowledge graph you can
actually do almost all of that maybe not
that making jokes part but that's kind
of a bonus but the hardest part of what
the computer actually did in that album
was listening to two different people
recognizing them and then responding to
each of them differently based on what
it knows about each person that is a
hard part it's the same thing happens
with the computer and Star Trek our
phones today are supposed to be able to
recognize your voice and respond to you
and not others yet for most people I can
just sit right here in this chair and go
okay Google hey Siri and like half of
you probably just had your phone go off
not even sorry so even with enough
training voice recognition between
multiple people as the only difference
is really really hard not to mention
it's super easy to fake someone's voice
bite not just sounding like them but
with a recording so half of this goal is
kind of realistic and half seems really
far off
I'll give it like a 5 out of 10 now
number four is this one's crazy flexible
smartphones every single flexible
smartphone demo I've seen looks crazy in
some way the goal is to have a
completely flexible smartphone you can
just wrap around anything shape it
whatever you want fold it put it in your
pocket I don't know wrap it around your
wrist there's all kinds of things you
could do with a flexible smartphone but
I don't think this one happens anytime
soon for a bunch of reasons why number
one in order to have a flexible
smartphone you don't just need a
flexible display you need every single
component inside the smartphone to be
flexible - and we have flexible displays
as you've probably already seen but
you'll notice that every single one of
those is connected to some sort of brick
at the bottom or the end a brick that
holds you know the rest of the
smartphone the processor the RAM the
storage the battery none of which are
flexible at all
but - even when you just think about
something folding in half you have two
surfaces and that means the surface on
the inside where it folds needs to be
able to compress and the surface on the
outside needs to be able to stretch and
if you fold both ways
both sides need to be able to do both
all that makes a very
malleable material which means it's not
very durable it's just not a good recipe
for building a smartphone at oh so
that's why pretty much every flexible
smartphone demo is really just a
flexible display demo now lenovo did
make a flexible smartphone concept last
year like a fully flexible phone in one
direction and it kind of had its
internal components spread out and laid
out just perfectly so that you could
fold it along certain predetermine lines
but obviously that's a lot uglier and a
lot less useful than the goals we had in
mind plus I'm not even sure a flexible
smartphone is what we really want anyway
so overall I give this one about a 4 out
of 10 so number 5 last but definitely
not least is a battery technology
breakthrough and I know this is the
second one about batteries since we had
wireless charging but hey batteries are
kind of a pain point with smartphones
and this one's more of a long shot than
any but graphene batteries we can work
with lithium technology all we want and
it'll keep getting better as it does we
get little density increases we get
better layouts charging it's a little
bit faster new designs like stacked
battery cells are awesome but at the end
of the day they're powering more and
more powerful devices and through years
and years and years of development our
smart phones still last one day if we're
lucky so there's always articles and
talks about some breakthrough battery
technology that might not be lithium
based at all not lithium-ion not lithium
polymer just completely new graphene is
one of the most promising materials out
there if you haven't heard of it it's
definitely worth reading up on it's
essentially just a sheet of pure carbon
atoms that's just one atom thick so
basically a 2d material in this form
it's completely transparent when it's
this thin it has a ridiculous strength
to weight ratio light is air but
literally harder than diamond and it's
one of the most electrically conductive
materials - even more than copper that
we already use everywhere so people want
to use graphene to make all kinds of
stuff in all kinds of different
industries if we could make smartphone
batteries out of this kind of thing or
car batteries or any battery we could
get almost superconductor like
performance and possibly have charging
up in seconds while the charge lasts for
weeks I mean that's the goal so the
reason we're not going to see it super
soon is the manufacturing prowess to
make this stuff is not there like at all
the first way humans ever found graphene
was by taking some scotch tape taking
some graphite off a pencil and just
peeling it apart over and over again to
get thinner and thinner slices until
some
flakes happen to be that sheet of
one-atom-thick graphene that's not even
producing graphene that's just stripping
carbon sheets from the end of a pencil
tip the most efficient manufacturing
processes today can make a sheet of
graphene that's maybe the size of a
playing card or an index card for a
little under $1,000 but that's still
very little material because it's only
one atom thick as you can imagine is
very very hard to manufacture materials
that are one atom thick overall I give
this for feasibility about a 2 out of 10
so there you have it stuff from the
future versus stuff we have now maybe
let me know which one you're most
excited for personally I'm all on board
with the super thin side bezels also
take the top and bottom bezel I like
front facing speakers I don't mind those
but give me those those melting over
glass sides I'm kind of a big fan of
that either way that's been it thank you
for watching feel free to share this
video and I'll talk to you guys in the
next one peace
[Music]